Pilar, take it away.
Teach us how to cook pasta.
Amatriciana.
Out of the essentials of Italian cooking
by Marcella Hazan on page 157.
We want you to cook with us.
So you at home who are kind enough to be watching us
please submit photos, videos, anything you got
to join us in this culinary venture.
All right.
Lynn, Daniel and Zenobia
feel free to ask questions while we go.
Pilar, take it away.
All right.
So we're doing them Amatriciana sauce.
And one of the reasons why I love this pasta is
because it's super simple and it has pancetta in it.
And it uses bucatini pasta
which is one of my favorite, favorite pasta shapes.
It's like a spaghetti sexy cuts in, you know
it's like bouncing.
I like it.
All right, so first we're going to do,
you're going to add two tablespoons of oil.
Right there.
Yup, looks so clear.
Yup, it is a vegetable oil.
Ah, and we're going to do one tablespoon of butter.
And over here we have one medium onion.
Does it matter what type of onion you use,
could it be like red?
So I think that for this recipe, they use a yellow
which is kind of the standard workhorse onion.
Vidalias could be used but those are a little sweeter.
White onions as well.
But I am actually a shallot fiend.
And if you were looking to substitute
a different kind of onion,
I feel like give shallots a go for sure.
I love them.
So the onions now are getting sort of pale and golden
and now we're going to add in our pancetta.
So basically pancetta is uncured pork belly.
And we're just going to saute that
for about a minute to let the flavors meld with the onion.
Zenobia, you had a question for Pilar?
Yes, I do.
Can the pancetta be substituted for regular bacon?
Will it take away from the recipe?
That's a really good question.
So things like guanciale and pancetta are actually
cured pork products where they're not smoked,
whereas bacon is a smoked product.
So just be mindful that when you're using that,
the bacon's actually going to be less salty
but it's going to give it that smoky flavor.
And now we're going to add
in our one and a half cups of chopped canned tomatoes.
And we're going to give that a good simmer.
I have a question about the sauce.
Yes?
So when you add the tomato sauce,
sometimes I find that I simmer it too far down.
Is it okay to add some more of that tomato sauce?
Absolutely.
So what I like to do when you drain off a can of tomatoes
is actually reserve the liquid until you're finished cooking
because sometimes it might reduce too much
and you can always add more later.
So definitely keep the sauce until you're done cooking.
So you make sure all your bases are covered.
Great, thank you.
Can you use fresh tomatoes?
So you can, they're gonna take a little longer
to cook down.
And what I would recommend is
if you're going to use fresh tomatoes
really use them at the height of their season.
That way they're going to be extra, extra delicious.
And do you want seed or deseed?
I don't mind the seed.
I feel like deseeding in the kind of sauce like this
is going to get a little more fussy
and it's not necessary, but you can use plum tomatoes.
You can use Marzano tomatoes, fresh, like in-season.
Just know that it's going to cook down a little longer.
So we have this beautiful sauce over here
and I added some chili flakes, red chili flakes to taste.
And then basically you have that sauce going
for about 25 minutes, just simmering on low.
Are we switching, 21, 23.
Voila!
Ah, beautiful.
So we have this beautiful sauce it's been reducing
and now comes the fun part.
We're going to toss in our bucatini into the sauce,
right into the sauce.
Right onto my thighs.
That's true.
Pilar, why the bucatini versus a different type of pasta?
Good question.
So the sauce is actually from a region specifically
or a place in Italy where bucatini
is one of their traditional shapes.
It also has this hole in the middle of it.
So it sops up even more sauce, which is really, really nice.
But you can use any long shape that you like,
spaghetti would work really nicely as well.
All right.
Last thing we're going to add to this beautiful sauce.
Here we go.
We're going to do three tablespoons of parmigiano-reggiano
and two tablespoons of pecorino.
And you're going to give that a good mix.
Oh, parmigiano and then the pecorino?
Yeah, so it's two cheeses,
which is really exciting for me.
Are we ready to plate?
I was just going to say I got the ladle out!
All right, so I am plated up here.
How are you doing, Drew?
I am very excited because I think everybody here knows
that this show is an entire ruse for me to eat my face off.
(laughing)
And you can finish it with a little more cheese
as you wish.
I'm going to grate some more just over the top.
All right.
Did we get to try it now?
I sure hope so.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Again, I feel-
Do we get to try it?
I know, I feel horrible.
You guys are gonna watch us eat this delicious food.
All right, next time.
The surfers cookbook club.
I'm thinking next time, we'll make sure
that you have those dishes in front of you
because now I feel guilty.
It looks so good.
All right, ready?
I'm just going to tell you it's horrible, Daniel,
no matter what.
It sucks, you guys.
(laughing)
You guys, it's incredible.
Thank you guys for joining us.
See you next time.
(clapping)
Exactly.
I want to thank everybody for joining us
and I want to make a special announcement.
That cookbook club is something that's really meaningful
and it's about building a community
and we want to donate $5,000 to the Monday night hospitality
at the All Souls church here in Manhattan
which is very near and dear to my heart.
It's a place I've spent time.
Actually, my daughter has also delivered food there
on holidays
and we're going to continue to find places such as that
that provides food to people in these meaningful ways.
So I just want to thank everyone
for joining us today for Cookbook Club,
Lynn, Daniel, Zenobia.
You guys are so awesome.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for kicking off our very first Cookbook Club
and obviously chef Pilar.
(upbeat music)